all right making big news over the
weekend is a short video clip in which
Jared Kushner Donald Trump's son-in-law
attacks or criticizes may be better said
Ron desantis's Martha's Vineyard
immigrant stunt now as a reminder this
is the stun in which Ron DeSantis
sent via plane migrants awaiting Asylum
adjudication in Texas to Martha's
Vineyard a small island off the coast of
Massachusetts lied to them promised jobs
said you're going to Boston you're going
to get expedited uh regular
normalization of your immigration Senate
all these different lies lured them
there potentially illegal using these
people's uh lives essentially as
political pawns so a big deal was made
of the fact that Jared Kushner went on
Fox News
and he said he was against it he said he
doesn't like what Ron DeSantis did
there is a very specific self-serving
reason why he said this and many of you
already know what it is let's look at
the clip and then discuss I also we have
to remember these are human beings
they're people so seeing them being used
as political pawns one way or the other
is is very uh troubling to me okay
Jared's against it he says these are
people seeing these people used as
political puns is troubling to me
wow that's that's true I agree with that
right well let's just think of both the
hypocrisy and the real reason for this
number one
the hypocrisy is that during Trump's
presidency
he tried to do something very similar he
said uh if there's an interview where
Mark Miles Taylor spoke about this
Trump said let's bus immigrants from the
border
and put him in Democratic cities and
Trump actually wanted to Trump's idea
was let's find the ones that are that
are criminals and bring them to
democratic cities so Trump wanted to do
the exact same thing there's no moral
High Ground here for what Jared Kushner
is saying the reason why Jared Kushner
is saying this is very very simple
in the betting markets Ron DeSantis has
now taken a lead over Donald Trump
in terms of who is expected to be the
Republican Presidential nominee in 2024.
we have seen this fight growing now for
months and months
Donald Trump increasingly was furious
with Ron DeSantis because when Ron
DeSantis was asked about running in 2024
DeSantis didn't say well I would only
consider running if Trump doesn't want
it Trump is mad at DeSantis because
Trump wants DeSantis on his knees uh
praying at the altar of trump and saying
if the orange fearless leader wants the
nomination I will get out of the way
DeSantis hasn't done that and that has
caused anger for Donald Trump and slowly
but surely over the last year we have
seen in the betting numbers remember
this is when people bet on who they
believe will be the nominee not polling
the betting numbers have shifted more
and more and more away from being in
Trump's favor to the point where now Ron
DeSantis by a small margin is favored to
be the Republican 2024 nominee in the
betting markets this is why Jared
Kushner is taking the opportunity to
attack DeSantis it's not because of an
actual moral conflict here where he
doesn't like what it is that Rhonda
Sanders did because Trump tried to do
the exact same thing that's what this is
about and my hope is that it gets very
very ugly between Trump and DeSantis My
Hope Is that Trump wants the nomination
and that so does the santis and that
they get into a big to do and it just
sabotages them that would really be the
goal one of our sponsors today is blue
chew a unique online service delivering
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping